being in charge is great you know what i
mean especially if you especially if you
think you have better ideas
you know um but no with especially with
this show you know i'm a producer on the
show
but
i didn't create the show though i didn't
create this show
or producer on the show but i do have
some say and the rest of the producers
and creators are very collaborative they
they're not like
they're not like this is our way or the
highway you know i get the scripts we
take notes we make changes
um that i think that's important
especially being a producer is to be
able to collab with the people who are
smarter than you in those areas always i
am and ultimately i want to be adam
sandler man like i
i want can i be your david spade could i
be your nick schwartzen can i just be
like
please just have me come aboard somehow
please do man like i told you before man
i'm a huge fan of yours i'm a fan of
yours man hey let's let them work with
your friends work with people you like
exactly this though it feels like less
stress that way you know what i mean
that makes me happy everything's moving
and i i got to do a movie with adam
sandler once
and uh it was called sandy wexler sandy
wexler yes yes
and i was just watching how like there'd
be times where
kevin james is on set and he's not even
filming like he's just there in video
village tossing out jokes
like they just kick it they hang out and
they have fun and his family's there
i'm like this is the life man like now
yeah i hear like sandler and i love
sandler i love adam so he he came up to
me once i did this movie that didn't do
very well i've done a few of those but a
movie called sorority boys and he goes
you're really funny in that man you're
hilarious in that movie i go
yeah thank you yeah but don't worry
about it you're funny who cares
you know he's really sweet i heard that
you know sometimes on set
somebody told me like he'll be like he
when he's giving direction to his friend
he's like come on you can be deliver it
like that turn your head and then say
the line yes does he do that
he does and it's and it's the best
because it's it's not
it's not like coming from some
director that you don't know right you
know what i mean like some who's
like really pretentious and feels like
their job is the best in the world and
they're all powerful and they want to
talk down to you as the actor he's
around with his friends you know
what i mean yeah that's he can do it
i've seen him like his nephew i want to
say his nephew and even his agent was in
the movie i want to say or his manager i
think and he's yelling at them from
video villains and he's like just
sitting a line like this you're
supposed to be come on you act like you
never acted before come on do it like
this
and then just like
like shut up dude
did he do it with you did he kind of
throw at you
uh he would not not in not in the that
kind of way but we would we would play
like there was a scene i remember when
we were at the dinner table
and uh
and he we had to do this bit where he's
like choking he's like
talking and spitting out food and he's
picked like chicken at me and i'm like
kind of like disgusted with him but i'm
playing the scene so real
and so straight right and like and
he didn't know i was gonna play it that
way and so he got he goes come
on this dude is making me act
he's like all right he regroups he comes
back
and
he comes back and then maybe like 20
minutes later we reshoot part of that
scene his coverage
and he and then he reminds you why he's
adam sandler like he comes back he's
improvising
he's
heightening the scene he's low he's
playing high status low status he's
doing he's like an acting clinic after
he saw what i was going to do on my
coverage um so that's his most that's
the most
i've seen of him like make adjustments
and like get weird with me on sale he
was very like
so he's sort of he sort of does this
thing where he sees what you're going to
do and then on his close-up he'll go for
instance he's like uh you know he says
lamorne how's this chicken and then
he'll do one where he's like the man has
his chicken you like this chicken and
then he'll do so
whatever it is you know or he's yelling
at you something that he's spitting on
your face he'll do
different vocal he'll be high he'll be
low he'll do everything so they have all
these choices
absolutely absolutely because you know i
imagine a lot of times especially in
comedy the tone is very
it's a delicate line you have to walk
when you're trying to figure out the
tone for the for an entire two hour film
and in that scene in particular it could
have went so slap sticky based off of
what i could have done with the
performance but i i you know it's a
sadly movie so i wanted to just play it
real so his his comedy could get
heightened and be more polarizing and so
i played it straight and i played it and
it was hard to do as well just because
again i'm sitting across my head of
silence so there are moments where i'm
breaking but i'm like stop starting
myself going on okay okay
and i'm playing it straight so you were
breaking you were breaking up he broke
you a few times
oh a million times
like i mean a million times did he like
it do you think he liked breaking you
i oh i know for a fact he did i know
what he did because there are times when
he's just doing it specifically to break
you
like he's seeing like moments of like
if i do a bit here it'll with him a
little bit right um that was fun man it
was fun it truly was like a clinic
working on that film
you